now we've been discussing steady uniform
procession which is the simplest
possible case of a phenomenon that can
be much more complicated as an example
in the case we've been discussing so far
where we release a gyroscope from rest
when it's horizontal very careful
measurements would show that the initial
motion isn't just steady procession but
has some additional motion superimposed
on it the spin axis sort of bounces or
nods up and down as it processes however
friction at the pivot point causes the
amplitude of the knotting to rapidly
decay until it settles into steady
procession this nodding motion is called
nutation in our example it decays so
quickly that we don't even notice it
but if you had a perfectly frictionless
pivot point it would be it would be a
more noticeable effect and it would
persist for much longer now there's an
interesting point about our horizontal
gyroscope that I'd like to point out
here is my rod of length G this is my
point s here's my wheel that's rotating
with some angular velocity and again
there's the R hat direction that's the
direction that little Omega vector is
pointing in that's the K hat direction
and that's the theta hat direction
now before I release it before I release
it Java's go from rest the angular
momentum vector points in the R hat
direction as John at this instant when I
released from rest there is a torque
acting in the theta hat direction that
causes the angular momentum vector to
rotate and we've seen this in some
detail but there's something else to
keep in mind which is that now when the
system is processing that means that the
center of mass of the wheel is orbiting
around the z axis the vertical axis
through this pivot point
okay so you can think of that as a point
mass with the full mass of the gyroscope
moving in a circular path around Point s
with a radius D that implies that there
must be a component of angular momentum
pointing in the K hat direction pointing
along the z axis corresponding to the
translational motion of the center of
mass a circular translational motion of
the center of mass of the gyroscope
around the z axis but where did that K
component come from there was no initial
Z component of the angular momentum we
said that initially the angular momentum
just pointed in the r hat direction and
there's no torque in the K hat direction
the only torque is in the theta hat
direction so how do we end up with some
angular momentum pointing in the K hat
direction this seems to violate the
conservation of angular momentum the
solution to this puzzle is that in fact
the gyroscope doesn't remain precisely
horizontal when I release it instead it
dips by a very small angle so that's the
horizontal after I release it the
gyroscopes actually dipped downward by a
small amount of exaggerated it
considerably in this drawing call that
angle Delta Theta that small dip gives a
small negative component of the spinning
and a momentum that's able to balance
the plus Z angular momentum due to the
motion center of mass now because the
spin angular momentum vector has such a
large magnitude that's my spin angular
momentum vector
only a small angle is necessary in order
to get enough of a negative LZ component
to balance out the LZ corresponding to
the center of mass motion okay but what
we see is that although gyroscopes seem
like a remarkable system they're not
magic and in fact angular momentum is
conserved the faster little Omega it the
larger little Omega is the faster the
spin angular momentum of spinning or
velocity is and therefore the larger the
vector L is the smaller that angle is
and the less of a tip that you get so
now we can write the exact angular
momentum for the gyroscope
this is my distance D this is my pivot
point s my spin angular velocity it
looks like that
here's the R hat direction the K hat
direction and the theta hat direction
into the screen and we're orbiting the
precession is around z axis with an
angular speed capital Omega now recall
that the total angular momentum with
respect to point s can be written in two
parts
there's the angular momentum due to the
translational motion of the center of
mass and we know the center of mass is
just orbiting around the z axis so I'll
call that in fact the orbital angular
momentum so this is due to the
translation of the center of mass with
respect to point s and then the second
term is due to the rotational angular
momentum or spin angular momentum
relative to the center of mass so this
is due to rotation about the center of
mass so again the general Lang and the
momentum of the rigid body is equal to
the center of mass translational angular
momentum plus the angular momentum due
to rotation a pure rotation about the
center of mass so let's write each of
these terms the orbital angular momentum
that is the translational angular
momentum and center of mass is just due
to the motion of the center of mass of
the gyroscope which is at radius D with
respect to point s moving in a circle
with angular speed
capital Omega okay so that's equal to
the mass times the center of mass
velocity times the radius of the circle
and that angular momentum is in the K
hat direction but the center of mass
velocity is just equal to since it's a
circular motion it's just equal to the
radius of the circle D times the angular
speed of the circular motion of the
center of mass which is capital Omega so
I can write this as M capital Omega D
squared in the K hat direction so that's
the angular momentum due to the
translational motion of the center of
mass around point yes what I'm calling
the orbital angular momentum now the
spin angular momentum we've been talking
about the rapid spin of the wheel around
its axis so that's given by the moment
of inertia about that axis times the
spin angular velocity and that's
pointing in the R hat direction but
there's a subtlety here it points out it
turns out that is not the only rotation
about the center of mass that this wheel
is undergoing and actually because of
that I'm going to call this I 1 and let
me just draw a picture here so for my
disc rotating around this axis the
relevant moment of inertia is what I'll
call I 1 and for a disc we know that
would be 1/2 M R squared
the other rotation is a subtle one
notice in this drawing suppose I were to
draw a dot on the outside face of the
wheel when this wheel processed around
180 degrees to the other side that outs
that dot on the outside would be facing
in the minus R hat direction now or
would be pointing in to the left rather
than to the right and what that means is
that this disk has actually rotated
about its diameter so this disk has
rotated around a diameter like this and
that rotation is at the slower angular
speed capital Omega and it takes one
full orbit for it to rotate entirely
around if that rotation weren't
happening it wouldn't this wouldn't make
sense physically the way I have to set
up but as an object if that rotation
weren't happening what that would mean
is that this face with the dot on it
would always be pointing to the right as
the disk moved around if it had an
independent pivot point right at the
center it would be physically possible
for it to do that that's not what's
happening in this case in this case this
face is always pointing outward radially
away from the pivot point and that
results in a rotation around this
diameter that turns out that moment of
inertia which I'll call I 2 happens to
be half the moment of inertia for this
axis so in this case it's 1/4 mr squared
ok so that is another kind of rotation
that's happening about the center of
mass and so there's an additional
angular momentum term arising from that
rotation and that's equal to I 2 times
the angular velocity of that rotation
which is capital Omega and because the
axis there
z-axis this is pointing in the K hat
direction so the total angular momentum
of the gyroscope is I 1 times Omega in
the R hat direction plus I 2 times
capital Omega in the K hat direction
plus M Omega capital Omega D squared in
the K hat direction the first term the R
hat component is the only part that's
rotating so this is a rotating vector
the K hat terms are constant this is the
exact expression for the angular
momentum of the gyroscope and now we see
the jars gothic approximation more
precisely is saying that this rotating
term dominates over the other two terms
so it's actually that this term is very
large compared to either of these two
terms which as we can see is roughly
equivalent to saying the little Omega is
very large compared to big Omega